I go to the cinema all the time cuz I
like watching movies uh even bad movies
I love watching bad movies too cuz
that's how I have my uh you know my my
kind of you got app set you got to watch
the bad to appreciate the good you know
uh so I watched I watched two films
recently I watched uh the Martin scorey
film um I really want to watch that all
the new one yeah and it's [__] it's so
long it's three and a half hours right
no it's like three hours and 40
something okay I'm running up that's
what the Irishman was as well dude the
Irishman was like three hours 50 or
something dude it's so long it was so
long is it worth it um I think
so I dude it's one of those movies that
when you come out of it every school
sayy film review it's so damn long but
it's pretty good no you kind of leave it
and I was just glad it was over like I
I this happens with movies sometimes
that even if it's a really good movie
the moment you you go to check your like
watch or you go to get some kind of time
indication to be like how long have I
been here for where you're like I kind
of I'm getting the feeling I want this
to end and I definitely felt that way
about two two-ish hours in I was like
okay it just takes um uh killers of the
uh killers of the flower Moon he of the
flower Moon
um I mean I won't spoil anything but I
actually think I for once in a mon C
film I didn't really like lard DiCaprio
much in it and also
wow I was kind of like I was like man I
think he's like the weakest part of this
film a weird way okay I mean of course
dairo is in it yeah dairo is great in it
I meano ISO yeah Brendon Fraser is
really [__] weird in this film it
feels like he misunderstood the mission
yeah it felt like everyone is playing a
character and he kind of comes in
playing like a different time it was
very odd right uh I love that dude
whenever he's in that Jesse plem guy
yeah Tom Tom white that's his whenever
he's in a movie it's true true I've seen
this on T people M whenever he's in
something you know it's going to be a
banger he's such a terrifying actor
whenever he's in something he's always
really scary anyway um yeah it's it's
it's a little long I also when when the
reviews came out for it I saw the
reviews and everyone was saying that the
main uh the main uh female lead was was
really good and I I thought I thought
she wasn't very good at all yeah I feel
bad saying that but I felt like there
was like no emotion it's just a lot
you'll see what I mean you're sitting
there and and it's just so long and for
a good period of time the same kind of
thing just keeps happening and you're
like okay I I get it I get it the
feature review is will someone tell
Marty he needs to edit his
movies I I genuinely think right if this
was a 2hour 50-minute film it would have
been great like I think that's how I
felt about the Irishman as well I was
like this this could have been under 3
hours easily I know I know he loves to
do this thing it was a great movie but
was too long he loves to do that thing
where he lets dialogue scenes really
stretch and I think sometimes it really
works and other times it's like hey I
know this worked in another film but I
do not care cut this down I mean it
worked in Taxi Driver so he was like I'm
just going to keep I just think it was
too long I I think if I had a rid it out
of 10 I'd give it like
a I feel like it's such a cop out saying
seven but I don't have any strong
feelings on either side like I cannot
sit here in good faith and say it's a
bad film but I can't sit here and be
like it's a [__] bang that's that's a
pure and then I watched this [__]
awful movie called five five nights I
did watch that too [__] dog [__]
movie awful movie I don't know any of
the law of FNAF right so I go into this
film I the only thing I've watched is
like a matpat film I heard mat in it the
only thing I've heard is that he says
that's just the theory in the movie so I
watched it I watched it the day came out
right yeah you should have seen my soy
jacked face when I'm sitting there and
then he [__] mat Pat turns around I
was
like I was like what and and then he
goes it's just a theory and I was like
Ain't No Way ain't no way they got him
to say it you know Scott coron just
jacked off to that he's like I finally
made him say
it and uh the rest of the film was so
bad it was so bad it was one of the most
[__] boring films I've watched in so
long and I think the it's an hour and 50
uh yeah it's 5.5 in IMDb and I think the
only people who are rating this highly
are people who love FNAF what's uh
what's the Ron Tomato score on this I I
want to see like the Metacritic score
dude I want to I want to see what like
the it is being and I think 29% this is
actual [__] but like viewers you
know how they they're like the [__]
critics say it [__] like Yeah because it
is [__] look at this this is 29%
audience score 88% list listen I'm Happ
I am happy to clown on critics like when
they this is why the crunch Road Awards
will never work man you give an audience
voting power and this is this is the
[__] like I I actually think I actually
think like I you know when they the when
the critics they generally had lower uh
uh critical reception for like films
like the Mario movie yeah you know I
felt like that was unfair but also there
was like a mad conspiracy going on
actually did you hear about this what a
lot of people were speculating that for
some reason and I think this is [__]
this is disclaimer [__] people were
saying that people were paying for bad
reviews the the that someone was uh one
of the advertising are doing it so that
it can be like a look at the [__]
critics they don't [__] know [__]
look at us we're the fans we know what
we want you know what I mean that's just
a theory that's just a theory because
you know there's there been there's been
this giant Trend lately where people
will see a movie that has fan ratings
High fan ratings and low critical
ratings is like a badge of honor it's
like look at the [__] critics getting
another L they don't [__] they are so
out of touch with what the people want
but this one actually [__] [__] the
viewers dude the critics are so right
this film is actually garbage and the
reason why it has high views uh high
ratings is because there's fans of FNAF
that are just [__] getting hyped
about it because a movie's being made
about FNAF and there's loads of FNAF law
that's dog [__] and also you know their
favorite their favorite are probably in
it as well you yeah and a lot of people
you know a lot the the audience of this
is targeting you know CU fash has been
around for a very long time you know
they're all young adults now or getting
getting can I see what the difference in
the Mario movie
was Mario movie that's my I think it
it's gotten a little better now but I
distinctly remember when it was out it
was just under 50% yeah see look at
this that's something that I can kind of
relate to because I genuinely went in
the Mario Bros movie and I'm like this
completely met my expectations of
everything I expected from a Mario Bros
movie wasun it was it was it was a fun
movie would I rate it highly as a movie
if I went to do it with a critical mind
no no but I was just like am I watching
this to see a Martin scy three and a
half
hours [__] Mario just sitting around
just talking with Luigi for 15 minutes
extended dialogue let's break down the
character dynamic between Mario and
Peach listen you could give me 4 hours
of Jack Black [__] around singing and
i' probably watch that like I would I
would just just do that uh you know like
I to me again this has been like a trend
that I really don't like that that just
a lot of movies are being galvanized by
low critical reception which which makes
me wonder what were you expecting out of
out of the I I was expecting nothing I I
went into it entirely I I went into it
expecting nothing and I was like maybe
it'll be and I got maybe maybe that was
a problem maybe yeah maybe I had to go
in there knowing the entire [__] law
because I saw on Twitter that people
were being like this reveal was crazy
and it turned out right this is like
this is going to show how I don't know
[__] there is two [__] Freddy fast
say right one is brown and one is
slightly like yellow oh the golden
Freddy yeah and I'm watching this film I
thought they were the same [__] dude
cuz it looks like the same can we pull
up the difference between these two
[__] if you just type in like two
Freddy's dude as a casual viewer of the
thing uh maybe images might come up
better trying to decipher or like
watching this and like Freddy versus
golden Freddy uh yeah maybe the FNAF but
I feel like in the you got to see it in
the film
version
um yeah so so in so oh okay yeah so yeah
yeah so in the movie you know he's kind
of like a brown hint and then the gold
one is kind of like a brownish gold
right it doesn't help the majority of
this game and the filmer in the dark
yeah and then but I guess this character
has a blue eye but I didn't know they
were different so I'm sitting here and
it's never
explained but then I go on Twitter and
everyone's like dude this was so raw
this reveal was crazy and and then I saw
a quote retweet of someone else being
like I and I felt very very validated so
I like I didn't even know they were they
were different because they just they go
if you don't know the law it's a pretty
bad movie cuz you so much of this is
like like
reveals fan service um and it was just
[__] it was so [__] and it was like
baby's first horror movie it was horror
for kids which I I first of all I'm a
hater right I don't I don't like this
genre of horror that is like horror for
kids I'm like that takes away genres I
mean what the films are in that all the
new video games that are all like
kindergarten thing but scary and it's
all B Basics and it's all this and but
this film was genuinely a horror film
for kids it was a scary film kids hate
loud noises souly and I felt like man
this takes away every aspect of what I
think makes horror good is that raw kind
of human uncomfortableness and now we're
just doing loud Bear yeah animatronic I
mean uh it's yeah very weird I mean
everyone was in high school once right
it's just hey man yeah but I love [__]
like back when I was 14 I thought
slander man was the goat you know and
now I think back to it I'm like that
[__] ass don't [__] lie there was a
slend is there a slender there is a SL
of course SL this was this was dog [__]
movie and I the fact that the fans think
this is good and it's red highley is
actually a joke and makes fans look like
they don't know anything about movies
let's let's see the slend slend man was
awful slend was SL I actually watched
this one oh no not even the memes could
save it not even the m not even the
audience like 8% versus 16% audience
score god damn that is the amount of IQ
points you'll lose actually 16% that's
the average age actually that you need
to be to watch them I also went to the
cinema and I watched a movie called uh
hypnotic uh starring uh Ben affle oh and
uh was it good holy [__] was it
bad holy [__] the only thing I can I can
compliment this movies that it was short
so I was out uh was it actually short or
was it short compared to the scorey film
it was an hour and 40 which I feel like
is like short now nowadays every film is
[__] 2 and a half hours and I hate
this trend true and in Japan it was
called domino domino domino so I'm
watching this film It's called Domino in
Japan and then like the [__] credits
start goes hypnotic like and I'm like
wait is this is isn't this Domino here
like anyway so the premise of this film
is that there are these people who exist
who can just hypnotize people on command
so they could be like gone that just
sounds like a HTI plot yeah yeah it's
literally like mind literally they'll be
like gone come and then you'll just come
yeah or like that is literally like 90%
of Mind break hentai there's like this
scene in the film where he's like uh I
guess he's like hey uh you should shoot
yourself and then he just shoots himself
and you're like okay I I think I get
this I think I get it and then there's
this whole like could never yeah right
and then that like the whole oh God and
they they have like these mind battles
and I [__] lost it they have these
mind battles and it's just they just
camera Zooms in on their faces and it
keeps cutting between them going
like where they're trying to like
influence each other's minds and it's
just a [__] story it it was so boring uh
and there was like a whole bunch of it's
like watching a stand fight without
being it was kind of like um now more
think about it um
what was the I think it's is it Mar SC
no Christ Nolan film with the me
dreams like imagine baby's Inception
like they had a kind of similar thing
where it's like but it was all a
hypnotized dream and it goes on you're
like okay all right I guess that's fine
um yeah this looks [__] yeah this is
what happens when a less talented
director tries to make a Chris foren
noan film that's literally yeah that's
that's my feeling it literally felt like
if you had taken uh Inception and you
were like how do I make this dumber and
less cool yeah uh and Ben Affleck in the
film I thought was I swear Ben Affleck
sometimes just doesn't act he sometimes
just doesn't I feel like he just
sometimes just turns up he's like I'll
do it I think sometimes he's not even
aware he's being filmed but he's
actually like a decent actor I feel like
Ben affle can be good when he wants to
be but sometimes he just shows up and he
knows the movie is not going to do well
so he just kind of is like yeah is it
yeah yeah it's whatever for sure um so
it was a very I left the film feeling
like [__] I can't wish I didn't watch it
but also I like watching those films I
like having [__] to say about [__] films
um don't watch it uh is my
recommendation yeah it it really makes
hour and a half look like a Tik Tok you
know like compared to like the [__] 3
hours 40 of the schy film oh my God yeah
that was too long yeah I also had a bad
seed as well so I was kind of like list
time oh [__] I was literally that that
Meme of Willam
defo was yeah oh my God